My recent blood test shows some academia. I think you may have said that take it
and I heard something a little bit for someone with Hodgson's lymphoma was
all right. Would blood builder by megafoods be fine for about 30 days? So let's
look at this. So this person was kind enough to give the ingredients of this blood
builder by megafoods. Okay, so I heard as fermented, I heard a best glycinate. Good.
That means it's a double bond to glycine. So that's a good form of iron right
there, okay? Whole food could form a iron. Well, the good news stops right
there, unfortunately, because B12 as cyanokabolamine is the wrong, that's a
synthetic B12. That's not the four of B12 you want. You never want to take
something with cyanokabolamine. And then this gets even worse, folate as folic acid.
Folic acid is synthetic folate, which many have hypothesized scientists have
hypothesized the increase of the use of synthetic folate, which is folic acid, has
what has caused the MTHFR defects in people. So this is like this should be
outlawed. I mean, literally this product folic acid should be outlawed. So any
company still using folic acid, they're the dark agents. This is really bad.
This is what's actually added to enriched foods that makes it so bad for you.
Vitamin C is the scorbic acid. So like 15 milligrams, it's probably incidental.
Organic beetroot, that's fine. Food blend, that's fine. Good. These two things, this
especially is poison. So do not take this. Take our clear iron, use that product,
instead of clear iron. Also eating foods that are beet root is good for you.
That's a good thing to help build your blood, especially this time of year. You
could get that readily over to my house. I have it growing in my garden.